me
宇宙をもう特別なものにするのは少しやめませんかと
そういったお話をさせていただきたいなと思います
あの宇宙がそこが特別だからそこに行けば自分も何か特別になった気がする
そんな風に思って宇宙に行っちゃう人がちょっと家の山にも増えすぎてるんじゃないか
なっていうのが僕は思うことです
えっと5年前僕はある実験の候補者でした
2013年にザマーズソサエティという団体が始めた
茂木稼い実験という実験その候補者なんですねクルーの候補者だったんです
その模擬稼い実験というのは今写真の方に写っている
こんなような場所
まあ
ここですね地球にある火星というふうに思ってですね
そこが本当の稼いだよそういうふうに思って
実験をする人が入って基地に入って生活をする
そんな実験でした
世界でねそういう地球にある火星というのはまあいくつかあるんですね
ここは北極ので坊島という島
ここにはクレーターがありますこういったふうにですね
あの地球にある火星というのは文明から遠く離れている場所
そして隔離されていることそしてターサーの目的になるような
クレーターですと加工があるような場所こんなところが地球にある火星として選ばれ
ます
あとこのほかにもですねハワイ島にあるマウナロア火山ですとかあるいはユタ州にある
上ね砂漠
そういったところが地球にある火星として有名ですそして
a まぁそこにはですねまぁ例えばなさ
とかそのまず最低とかが基地を立てて長期の主レーションを今も実験してるんですね
でまぁあの模擬稼い実験というので一応外に松岡生ですから
外でた時は宇宙服の偽物なんですけどその来なきゃいけない
そんなものなんですが簡単に言うと日制5校です
しかもね本気の本気の火星5位大人が本気による火星国なんですね
まあ先ほど行った the まず society というのは20年ぐらい前から
こうしたシュミレーションの実験をやってみてですね
かなり老舗のような団体ですが
えーまぁその老舗の団体がまあ英史上最も過酷な場所で史上最も多様性のあるクルー
そういったフレコ
3である工房始めたんですねそれが僕の
参加した攻防だったわけです
ますつまりはですねまあ本気の中のさらに本機のか星5個
そして7名のクルーを先行で選ぶそんな計画でした
僕はですねまあその7人のうちのクルーとして日本人から唯一選ばれました
副隊長たいもさせてもらったんですけれども
まぁちょっとねこれ自慢なんですけど実は書類選考に残った200人くらいの候補者の
中から僕がトップで選ばれたんですね
あります
まああの先行の音担当してた責任者からはこんなことも言われました
あの他の候補者たち
履歴書とかあるいはそんなスピーチとかもしますのでそういったものを見るともう
みんなすごいも誰欄でいいのってくらいすごい経歴の人たちばかりが来たと
ただですね実際にその訓練を始める
その過程になるとまぁ特にですね共同生活なんかさせるとちょっとガッカリしてしまっ
た結果になってしまったと
僕に関してはあなたは最初全然目立たなかったのよと
だけど実際頭の共同生活で現場に出てみるとそのバランスそしてまあその現場での実力
っていうのがとても素晴らしかったと
あとはですねやっぱり専攻なのでお互いみんなライバルなわけです
そういった中で個性も強いお互いのライバルの中であなたのことだけは何も悪い風に
言わなかった
そういうふうに終わりました
まああのなんでですね僕はこんな
トップでがバレちゃったのかなあっていうの自分なりにその理由というかそういった
ものちょっと考えてみると
たぶんね僕は肩の力が1人抜けてたんですねあのというのも僕あんまり火星に行きたい
と思ってないんですね
そうなんです他の皆子を稼いに行きたい人たちの中でこれだけが思ってなくて
まあね最近本当に火星に近い男なんてたまに読んでいただけるんですけどちょっと誤解
があります
8僕はですね専門は建築なんですね
極地の建築
極地で誰かが来るシーンでほしくない
そういうふうに思っていますもちろん稼いでも
そういうですね本来なら人が住めないような場所
そこで人はどうやってどんな住まいだったらそこにとどまって暮らしていけるのか
あるいはそういう場所で人は何を支えにして生きていけるのか
そういうことが僕の一番の関心の中心にあります
だから僕はこの30代はそういうことを知りたくてずっと曲地と言われる場所に
進んできたわけですね
例えば北極南極エベレスト
富士山頂そういった場所で進んできました
まああのトータルするとですね日数的には1000日を超えまして
あの仏教の世界でも千日回峰行ってですね
厳しい修行があるわけなんですけどまぁぼちもち悟り広いってもいいかなというふうに
は思ってですがまだちょっとかなっていうふうに思います
僕がですねまあそういった相撲を関心としているわけなので
僕がやっぱり見ているのはですねそこにいる誰かなんですね
だからどこかっていうのはあんまりそんなに問題にしていない
だから火星っていうねそんなに重点がないというかなんですね
そこにいる誰かがすごく第4マナで正の先の受験中にヤボがあんまり
汗本当は行きたくないんだよねってちょっと言ったらちょっとねぇ
情報が書かれてて穴って跳弾なんだが本機何度かなんかそんな感じで言われる
でちょっとや外を稼いなんだけどみたいなんかね
そんな感じになりました
ただですねもう振り返ってみると大昔の僕らとの宇宙の関係を考えてみてほしいです
大昔というのは本当に宇宙と関係のない人なんかいなかったはずです
今みたいに選ばれた人たちのものだけじゃなかった
昔の人たちは例えばですね例えば月食日食
あるいは惑星のご多用の動きそういったものを観測してそしてその規則性から暦今皆
さんが使っているカレンダーを作ったですそういう意味では僕らのその日常の暮らしと
いうのは宇宙とが切っても
はせないそんな関係に昔からあったんです
ただ
現代の宇宙というのはちょっと違います
まあ一部ではあると思うんですがその例えば自分のやりたい欲求ですとか利益ですとか
そういったものを中心してしまう投資家あるいは一部の科学者たち
そういった人たちが絵馬リードするですねターン数
た計画とかいろんなものがありますねそういったものをがまあ中心になってきてしまっ
ているのではないかなというふうに思います
ただその宇宙という現場でそのうちを便利にする
あるいは自分たちの正しさを宇宙で証明したい
そういったものが自分の思いの中心になってしまっていることで一般の人たちにとって
はなんかちょっと遠くなっちゃったな
そんな宇宙になってはしちゃう
焼かないしないかなと思いますとにかくそのうちをですね
すべてそして自分の手に収めたい
そんなことが宇宙との関わりになってしまっていいのかなと
が少します
それとですね
印ですね
特別なもの宇宙ってものを定義してこれは特別なんだよっていうふうに定義してそれに
例えば無さとか
jaxa とかそういった高校人の印というか冠をつける
そしてアこれは宇宙の冠には違いますとか
うちの冠似合ってますねとかそういう風にして
しまうっていうことがやっぱりあるんですよね
僕もあのよく取材なんかでですねあなたのこのミッションや素晴らしいんですがこれ
なさとと関係してるんですかってのねまぁ必ず聞かれるんですよね
まあそのまず支えて来なさと関係あるわけじゃないのでただまぁその記者さんたちがね
気持ちもすごくよくわかって読む多分
なーさんもそうなんですかな5年 nasa 公認とかなんかついてないとこの記事
などこれコザ安いやつだなみたいな感じの生地になってしまうかなという気もします
まああの僕はですねあのあんまり目立つ
得意なものが実はあんまりいないんですね
小さい頃からあのビビリで
つ6秒で
そしてまあよく言えばですね費用ビンボってやつですね
まあどれも普通にそこそこまあできるのでまぁそう言うなバランスがいいとかっていう
ふうには何ですけど特別なものがあまりないんです
ただあの運はね南極越冬隊なってみれば選ばれないといけないのでそういう意味では
結構大変でしたけど選ばれたっていう運もあるのかなというふうな気がします
ただ昔から取り柄が生まれなかったですが今の僕には経験ならあります
経験というのは本当に積み重ねですそしてこれからも減るものじゃありません
まあ南極観測隊言ってたわけですけど
60年間も南極観測隊続いているんですよね
60年も続いている南極観測隊ってスーパーマンみたいな人達ばかりじゃないんですよ
ね
例えば本当に転勤で仕方なく南極ちゃいましたとか
あとはそうですね冬の分連国内であるんですけど
いや行き始めてみたんですよねみたいな人も本当にいるんですよ
ただ求められる能力っていうのは派手さではありません
誰かのために継続していくそんな力が求められます
まあ
南極終わってから僕はその後エベレストに行き
南極のですねすごい厳しいんですがやっぱり日々ですねもう一つ一つ丁寧に暮らして
いく暮らし
建築の立場からするとすごいいろんな発見があった
だからきっとエベレストに行けば同じような発見がまた見れるんじゃないかなと思って
期待してベレスの方に
で迎えました
ただがっかりしましたそうじゃなかった
登山家のプラッシュというのはすごいイライラしてたんですね
あの僕は登山隊のエンジニアとしてベースキャンプの方にずっと入ったわけです
ベースキャンプというのはですねまあ登山家にとってはそのベースキャンプより先
それは朝鮮の場所です
すべてをそ業として挑戦をする
逆にベースキャンプというのは最後のシャバなんですね
だからも我慢しない
リラックスしまくり
その人の本当にやりたいことを英語がむき出しになるようなそんなギラギラした中環境
でした
たまたまですねその年すごく天候が悪かったんですね
その僕はその登山隊に合流する前に
刹那が飛ばなかったもので困ったなーということで
リプロでずっと実は歩いていったんです
1週間ぐらいかけてですね途中富士山くらいの投票は3つぐらんですけどそこずっと r
ティグダーって言うねえ本来のスタート場所の飛行場まで歩い
たんですその道っていうのはですね本当に観光客なんか全然いない場所で
本当にスポの現地の村人たちですね山の村人たちの生活のための街道だったんです
でも本当にですね素敵な場所だったんですね
なーんにもないんですよ
派手さもないし特別さもないんですけど決して豊かでもないんですけど
子どもたちの目がこうやってキラキラ自信を持った目をしているんです
だから僕はあのその後ベースキャンプに行ってそのベースキャンプが結局がっかりし
ちゃったから余計にこの道の素晴らしいことのばかりが思い出に残ってしまって本当に
そのこの道のおかげで点呼良かったのは良かったら行かなかったんですけどあの
悪くて終わったなと思ったんですけどネパールが本当に大好きになりました
大きな地震が2015年にあってその後はですね
特になんですけど毎年今でもこの道を誰かを連れてある気に入ってます
何曲もすごく
何もなくて素敵でした
エベレストヒマラヤの山にを山々はですね神様が住んでる山があるわけです
そして南極にはこうやって美しい氷山があるわけです
ただどれもですね特別な名前がついてなかったりするんですよね
もちろんそのどれが一番高いとかそういったのもあのついてません
まあ
山っていうのはですねその子の鼓動の横の山にはすべてヒマラヤなんです
だから区別もないで登ろうっていう山じゃないんですね
それは遠くから眺めて敬って
そんな存在の山々なんです
ネパール人たちは大昔は本当にそのヒマラヤに登ろうとなって誰も思いつきもしなかっ
たんですよね
だってそこは神様か本当は怖い化け物がでしか住んでない世界だから
そういう感じだったわけです
ところがですね西洋の考えがその後に入ってきました
それによって
高さですとかあるいは難易度ですとかそういったものに順番ですとかあるいは格式
みたいなそういったものをつけるようになりました
本来だったらですねそこに競争なんて無かったはずの場所です
だけど精鋭の考え方によって今皆さんのご存知のようにやっぱり競争っていうのが
たくさん生まれてしまいました
宇宙の現場っていうのも今これと同じなんですよね
宇宙っていうものにすごく特別な何かこう
冠が付きすぎている名前なんかも勝手に後どんどんつけていくわけなんですねまぁただ
確かに冠が付くといろんなものが集まってくるんです
人もお金も集まってきます中には
が目立ちたがり屋の人も来るしたりを実力のある人も来るし
まぁそうやってですね価値の足し算みたいなものが始まってどんどんどんどん高宇宙が
動き出していくんですね
現代ではその sns なんかもそのスピードを早めたりします
まあ僕はですね挑戦するっていう気持ちを決して僕は否定しようとは思っていないん
です
好奇心挑戦をする想像力っていうのは僕ら人間に与えられた最高の乗り物だと思ってい
ます
大昔は僕らを目視じゃないですね子供の頃は僕ら本当に紙飛行機1つあればあの家庭
宇宙まで飛んで行けたじゃないですか
ねっだからそういうのはやっぱり想像力の力だと思うし
大昔だってあの止めとペット言われてもほっそりね
もう行きたくて行きたくてこっそり上ったとあの人だってね
いたはずなんですよヒマラヤだって
でまぁそういった人たち
だけじゃなく今の時代にだってそういう土地の歴史であるとか場所をいろんなものに
畏敬の念そういうものを持った冒険家たちが今でもちゃんといるわけです
やっぱりそういう冒険なの背中をね僕は見てるとなんかやっぱりああいいな部の背中
美しいなあっていうの
いつも思ったりします
まあ
クラスとか
していく
っていうことっていうのはやっぱり日常なんですよね
でその日常の世界の中に特別な冠っていうものを落ち込んじゃうとまぁこれ大変なわけ
です
暮らしていく日常というのはそこにしか居ない誰か
その人と一緒に来ていくことなのに特別な冠がそこに入ってしまうといつもここでは
ないどこかばかり2校目がいってしまうわけです
そうすると自分の人間のうぬ漏れとか知識だとか
あるいは無冠詞さそういったものが
自覚のない中でむき出しになっちゃうんです
僕が体験してきた火星ごっこの暮らしというのはまさにそんな形でした
僕はですねギラギラした人たちじゃなくてキラキラした目をした子どもたち
こういう子どもたちですねあるいは地味でもいい
普通にいろんなことを続けられる人が来る時代そういう家の時代が早く来てほしいなと
いうふうに
思っています
だから今日みなさんにお願いしたいことが一つあります
宇宙を特別なものとだから
自分たちには関係のない場所そういう風に思うのはやめてですね皆さんがいつも誰かの
ために普通に続けていることそれを宇宙の世界の中にぜひ持ち込んでほしいんですね
そうすれば宇宙の暮らしというのはヒット素敵なものになるはずです
経験者の役割というのは新しい人たちをナビゲートすることだと僕は南極である先輩に
教わりました
そして安全もそうだけど楽しむことも忘れないでねという風に言われました
僕がナビゲートしますのでぜひ皆さん家を一緒に考えましょう
ありがとうございました
[拍手]